[Applaudissements]
papademos alors il n'ya pas côté droit
c'est bon c'est bon on a parlé de la
lèze tout à l'heure c'est bon alors là
si je suis rien d'autre à lui mais lui
son bras lui je mangerai sur lui ah non
mais lui-même à un accord et tout un
menu et demeure quand même pas combiner
des gens qui puissent santé à
transpiration qu'ils le sentent pas eux
mêmes artistes qui le plus sale pour hbo
autour de la table basse celle qui est
les deux qu'ils n'ont avoué pardon c'est
isabelle et eric à localement des
directives je savais qu'il n'y ait pas
de gauche je sais pas rectifié de
légende urbaine
je me lève tous les autres quand je me
lève à 3h30 du matin pour couillon et je
trouve dans ces cas là je fais le
minimum vital et je me la joues tu as
dit que tu allais de sous-vêtements à
jour sur deux par nyons élimé et toi tu
as dit que tu te l'avais dans un lavabo
chez toi parce que tu allais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
7,50 débat très bien c'était pas non
c'était pas prévu le 1er bouquet sont
donc pour vous pour vous et elles sont
sales oui si vous deviez manger sur le
corps de l'une des deux
laquelle est la plus sale pour vous et
quels aliments ouais alors pour des
raisons techniques alors il vous non
réponse après la pub ensuite retrouvé
dans un lac au nigeria martial qui mate